the long-awaited mullah report a
redacted version of it is available for
viewing but hours before Americans had
their chance to read it
president Donald Trump's Attorney
General had his say after nearly two
years of Investigation thousands of
subpoenas hundreds of warrants and
witness interviews the Special Counsel
confirmed that the Russian government
sponsored efforts to illegally interfere
with the 2016 presidential election but
did not find that the Trump campaign or
other Americans colluded in those
efforts but what about the possible
obstruction of justice by Donald Trump
ten episodes were examined to the Geisha
the president took no act that in fact
deprived the special counsel of the
documents and witnesses necessary to
complete his investigation the president
was quick to react and took to Twitter
to declare himself fully vindicated he
later appeared at an event in Washington
where he expressed his delight I'm
having a good day too who was called no
collusion no obstruction
there never was by the way and there
never will be
but Democrats criticized William bar for
holding a press conference before the
report had been released the Speaker of
the US House of Representatives Nancy
Pelosi currently on a trip to Ireland
took to Twitter and said bars partisan
behavior had triggered a crisis of
independence and impartiality she went
on to demand that special counsel Muller
provide public testimony in the House
and Senate as soon as possible
Democratic senator Elizabeth Warren said
it was a disgrace to see an attorney
general acting as if he's the personal
attorney and publicist for the President
of the United States the moa report
could not conclude that Donald Trump
obstructed justice but it's not over yet
for the President as Congress can
continue to investigate him let's go
straight to Washington then where we
joined DW correspondent Helen Humphrey
welcome Helena so 450 pages of this
reports been out a couple of hours now
how far have you got 450 pages if you'd
like a reference point field that is
longer than to kill a mockingbird we're
certainly combing our way through it I
just want to show you some of the level
of redactions that you can see in that
report we knew it would be redacted but
here you can see some of the pages are
completely blacked out and some of those
redactions are heavily related to
WikiLeaks in the democratic dumb of
emails in 2016 remember of course last
week we did see the arrest of Julian
Assange in London we can't speculate as
to whether that is connected but
certainly interesting development as to
the latest that we are now understanding
as we continue to read through this
investigation firstly that the president
was certainly perturbed by the
appointment of special counsel Robert
Muller trying to fire him when he
learned of his reappointment he
reportedly said according to this
investigation oh my god this is terrible
this is the end of my presidency he also
tried to thwart the investigation in
relation
to the FBI director James Comey
reportedly having him fired because he
was dissatisfied with the FBI director
not coming out to say that the president
was not under investigation in terms of
connections with Russia we now know that
polling data during the presidential
campaign was passed on to Russian
connections for far longer than we
thought we understand that the president
Donald Trump is reportedly sympathetic
to his former campaign manager Paul
Manafort who lied under oath about his
connections to Russian connections of
course in constant anchor limnic Muller
reportedly was not satisfied with the
written answers which he obtained from
the president but decided not to
subpoena for a sit-down interview with
the president because he didn't want to
delay this already two year-long
investigation and ultimately that the
special counsel could not rule that
there wasn't criminal conduct he clearly
wrote that that this does not clear the
president 14 other investigations are
ongoing 12 of which remain secret right
now so we saw the the president saying
in the report there that he's having a
good day tell us some more about his
response he said it was a good day he
tweeted his popular refrain of no
collusion no obstruction we have also
now had a statement from the Trump
campaign saying that this is a clear
example ocean no obstruction vindication
for him and now that the tables will be
turned that there will be an
investigation into the quote Liars so it
looks like hinting there at some revenge
to come hello Humphrey in Washington
thank you yeah and someone who has been
reading the reports like I have is Tyson
Barker right here a familiar face one of
our u.s. analysts and a veteran of the
Obama administration and now with the
Aspen Institute so you've been reading
those 400 pages today like the rest of
us what struck me is that President
Trump after the release took place said
he was having a great day
has he read that report well I think
he's having I mean the entire phalanx of
advisors from the White House's out
completely on the defensive today
Kellyanne Conway has already come out
and said that their misrepresentations
of what happened immediately after the
firing of Comey there have been a lot of
gaps in the narrative filled in for
example knowledge that Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner others hope Hicks were
aware that there was dirt on Hillary
Clinton being offered by the Russians a
lot of these these elements are being
laid out especially on the obstruction
of justice front and that's really where
I think a lot of the focus is going to
turn to well there were 10 cases in this
report where mother says you know we
were almost there in terms of
obstruction of justice the report
concludes that the the only thing that
separated Trump from obstructing justice
was the fact that the people he asked to
do that for him always said no that
could I read that and I thought well is
it this is something that's impeachable
then it's right there in black and white
isn't isn't that a massive irony that
and this a lot of this stuff has already
come out and Bob Woodward's reporting
from his book last year where he
basically said you know a lot of trumps
mandates to his staff Rob Porter
apparently Corey Lewandowski and others
were just not acted upon because the
staff knew that this would get the
administration in extremely hot water so
the irony here is that he actually has a
staff that's really looking out for his
best interest the question is is a
question of intent as I think you have
mentioned and others you know and when
does it become a prosecutable offense
and I think that what we're looking at
here and this has been indicated in some
of the footnotes in the report is that
this is something that basically Muller
said this is something for Congress
looking well is that what we're going to
see now I mean Mulder is going to
testify I mean today we heard the
Attorney General say he can do that
right I'm not against that so let's say
he goes to Congress and testifies and
then it's up to Congress to decide what
to do I mean the document the report is
no longer just a legal document it's now
a political document right impeachment
itself is political not legal right so
there are two avenues that this is now
going to take one is the political
Avenue which is going
have to do with Congress and the other
is going to be the prosecution's that
could occur the further investigations
that could occur for example by the New
York State Attorney General or in the
Southern District of New York the state
would be in a national attorney there
and those and one of the glaring
omissions from the report has been
Trump's finances in the state of Trump's
finances so there is some speculation
that a lot of the elements the evidence
that has been found in these
investigation was farmed out to others
to further prosecute which didn't fall
in the narrow mandate it very very
quickly the Democratic presidential
candidates and you know everywhere
across the country have been saying that
people aren't talking about this report
they're talking about health care the
the economy is this going to change that
do you think in the u.s. I mean I think
it's it's it's similar to frankly if you
think about back to Nixon and an
impeachment excuse me and his
resignation and Watergate a lot of the
the basic facts of Watergate were
already available in 1972 before the
1972 election what happened was it just
the the temperature continued to rise
through investigations and through the
reactions the White House itself and I
think that's where where this could
become a much more pressing matter for
the Trump administration Tyson Barker
thank you very much we look forward to
talking with you again tonight on the
day thank you